I’ve talked about the modern day trad wife before
modern day traditional wives
who are out there taking care of their man
who are generally hot
they take care of themselves and they usually cook, clean
do all the house chores
like they did back in the 50s
with ease
they don't complain
they're happy
why are they happy
they trust their man to lead the relationship
they respect him
depend on their man
there's nothing wrong with that ladies
they usually have their own business
so they're not just depending on their man for money
they're depending on their man for love, trust, loyalty
They’re not with their man for money
they might even make more money than their man
and they're still doing all the household chores
and satisfying their partners needs
because they like to
basically they get enjoyment out of life by taking care of their partner
these women are pretty rare but you do see them running around
they’re the happiest women out there
No, we're not in the 50s anymore
the year is 2024
but these women are still taking the ideology
that they should take care of their man
take care of their house
take care of themselves
They basically are just thriving in life
I don't know what do you guys think